Oh, okay. Avery, uh, what you got for
us?
>> Yeah. So, just hearing just hearing
what's going on here, man. I'm I'm a
Christian. I obviously disagree with
most Hebrew Israelite doctrine mainly,
um, on, you know, the nature of God,
whether he's triune or not, whether
salvation can be is only for the
Israelites, ethnic Israelites, or if
it's for, you know, everyone, even the
non the non-Israelites. So, I I disagree
with those matters. So, [snorts]
whatever you guys want to talk about.
>> Okay. So, uh you you pick which one you
want to talk about first. We can deal
with.
>> Okay. Sure. What do you guys uh believe
about Jesus? Do you believe he's
>> Wait, hold on, hold on one second. Hold
on one second now. Hold on. Hey, how do
you pronounce your name?
>> Me?
>> Yeah.
>> He said just Avery. Avery.
>> Avery.
>> Yeah. So, so, so you're not on here
dealing falsely, right? So, what what is
your real name?
>> I just told you it's Avery.
>> So, you go by God Logic.
>> That's my YouTube name.
>> Okay. So, you're God logic, the one that
has the debates with some of our elders,
correct?
>> That's right. That's me.
>> I'm just making sure cuz you didn't want
to say that. I just wanted to make sure.
>> Nobody asked. When you asked, I didn't
hide.
>> Yeah, but I'm saying like why would you
burner account though?
>> Well, my my other account my other
account's banned. Banned until the 17th.
That's why I'm on this one.
>> I thought you was hiding from your
groupies. Logic. I thought you was
hiding from your group.
>> No, I would I definitely come on my on
my main. We could get like a bunch of
people in here. But unfortunately, I got
banned, bro. So,
>> hey, got Logic. So, let let me ask you a
question. So, why would you want to
debate something that you you've already
been like what we saw and I'm just being
honest like if if when you were debating
Captain T or I've seen you uh I think
I've seen you go against what's that
guy's name? I can't think of.
>> Yeah. What's up?
>> Yeah. So, why why so why why do you want
to go through the same round and round?
>> Well, because there's still people who
are lost on these subjects. So like with
you with brothers like you and who hold
to these Hebrew Israelite doctrines
denying the deity of Christ, denying
salvation for non-Israelites,
you guys are still lost under these
falsehoods. So that's why I want to talk
to you guys.
>> Okay. But you do know that in the
classrooms the the videos and everything
that's being discussed between you and
our elders are are like um every single
word is is discussed and we're taught
right to go against people and to not
really listen to the false doctrines
that you guys teach.
>> You're saying that it's false doctrine.
You got to show me that it's false.
Brother,
>> it's already been shown. God b
>> Hold on. I know. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. But the thing is for me to sit here
and spend a spend an hour going back and
forth.
>> You don't have to, bro. Exactly.
>> No, no, I know. Hold on. But to like you
know that everything that Captain Jazar
went against against you on
>> Yeah. All of his points were
>> all those breakdowns. I have them
written in front of me right now.
>> Okay, good. So if you have
>> How are you going to
>> Hey, my brother, I'm with you. Latin
Heat. I'm with you. If you believe if
you believe that Captain Tazarak's
points refuted me, tell me now.
>> They did. Everybody here, everybody here
who's in Israel like give me one
real quick to me. Let's talk about it.
>> Hold on. God logic. Hold on real quick.
Hey yo, hold on real. All right. So
what? Let's deal with a particular topic
then, man.
>> Yes, let's do it. You know what I mean?
>> I want to debate him because he think he
hot [__]
>> I don't think I don't think I'm Let's
not do this [laughter] over confidence
thing. Let's Let's not do this thing as
hard.
>> Yeah,
>> you do want anything though,
>> right? So look, check this out. We gonna
um Gary want to bring out some points.
Just let Gary then you have that
conversation because Gary want to talk
to you.
>> I'm with it. Let's Let's talk about the
deity of Christ. That's what That's what
I as
>> All right. Go ahead.
>> All right. Hey, Gary. You ready? I know
you got that.
>> You know this [__] too easy. All right.
So, what do you want? What about the
deity of Christ?
>> Do you believe that he was created?
>> Of course.
>> Do you have a verse?
>> Yeah. Micah 5 and 2.
>> You said Micah 5:2.
>> Yep.
>> The verse that says that he's from
everlasting. It says his origin is from
everlasting.
>> So if his origin is from what does
everlasting mean, brother?
>> It means he comes from eternity.
>> So if he comes from eternity, that means
he has no actual beginning. He's from
eternity.
>> But that's contradictory to the word
origin.
>> No. No. Okay. Do you believe that uh God
watch
>> Do you believe that God was there in the
beginning?
>> No. I'm going to ask you a question.
What does eternity mean?
>> So now so now you're
>> Hold on. No, no, no. We talking about
No, we're talking about Michael 5 and 2.
What does eternity All right. So we said
it says origin. What does eternity mean?
>> Eternity is forever. It's infinite.
>> We don't have a beginning or or an end.
>> Okay. So, how does So, if Micah 52 said,
>> wait, before you ask, do you agree with
that? Like, like we got to make sure we
agree.
>> Yes. Eternity means no beginning nor
end.
>> Got it. Okay.
>> So, so hold on. So, if you look at Micah
5 and 22, oh Bethlehem fraud, and though
you be little among the thousands of
Judah, out of thee will come forth unto
me once who shall be ruler in Israel,
whose going forth, Musa, meaning origin
is from everlasting. So it means Christ
came from eternity. We know the only one
who is eternal is the father.
>> Wait, hold on a second. If he came from
eternity, that means that he's eternal
or else he did not come from eternity.
>> Look
eternal, bro.
>> Or Hold on. He can't be I I ain't mute
you. But
>> yeah, hold on before we continue cuz I I
want us to have a good conversation.
>> I don't want to have
I'm getting muted for no reason.
>> I don't want to have a foolish
conversation. Hold on. Hold on.
>> Hold on. Gary, you can continue. Dary
and you can't.
>> Darius, you told me that you guys let us
speak. Darius, you said
>> for a second. I got to say something to
my people again. You jumped in a in a
Israelite live. So, I need to make sure.
Remember remember Gary, his tactics are
to disrupt and redirect. He's not He's
not going to let you finish. He's never
gonna let you finish your your your
statement or get your understanding. And
he's supposed to be the Christian, the
one with the agape love. He's not going
to do that. This guy, he has tactics.
So, I'm just telling you, we study every
single thing. All the precepts he's
going to bring out. He only likes to
debate this topic. Also, I'm just I'm
just bringing that out.
>> I want him to I want him to I want him
to I want him Go ahead. Go ahead.
>> I want I'm going to go I want God I want
God Logic to refute this cuz he said
eternity, right?
>> Yo, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
>> What is that?
>> What the hell is that?
>> I'm just playing sad I'm playing sad
music cuz your boy crying
>> tactics, bro. Come on now.
>> Logic, man. Chill.
>> One second, brother. One second. I want
to show him this word, right? Cuz he
Hold on. I want to show him this word
cuz he thinks I'm saying y'all spending
too much time crying. I got to play the
violin for y'all.
>> I'm setting up good order. Both of y'all
please can one of y'all just start off
the conversation and then one of y'all
say I'm y I yield or I'm done.
>> No need to yield. Look, Gary and I can
have a back and forth. We were already
having a back and forth.
>> No, I just jumped in and started crying.
>> You just Hold on. Hold on. Let them just
talk because that's just the way how um
God Logic like to have that discussion.
As long as it ain't going crazy, let's
just hear them out. And once it start
going crazy, we going to stop y'all. I
just want to let you know God lo and
Gary, you know what I mean? But we gonna
let y'all go. Go ahead.
>> So wait, first hold on. Y'all know I'm
not new here, right? Y'all know like I
Gary, that's why I already know like
Gary, man.
>> All right. So wait, hold on. All right.
So All right. So you said origy. So it
this says Christ has a origin, but you
believe he's eternal.
>> What does it say? His origin is
>> from from everlasting.
>> There you go. So if
>> Hold on, hold on. What does the word
Hold on. What does the word from?
>> I'm letting you know, bro. I'm telling
I'm telling you.
>> Do you know the word What does the word
from come from?
>> If you listen to me, bro, if you if you
don't if you allow me to finish my
statement,
>> if you allow me to finish my statement,
I promise you, you'll understand what
I'm saying.
>> Listen, bro. I don't want to get muted
again. One thing guys, they're muting me
again. Hold on. Hold on. One thing I'm
just going to tell you one thing. All I
want you to do is have action.
>> I thought that y'all was better than the
Muslims and the Jehovah's Witnesses.
Bro, y'all y just as weird.
>> Y just as the only one getting muted.
Y'all are just as weird. What is this?
Hold on. Hold on. And then they kick me.
>> Y'all are just as weird. What is this?
>> Man. Hey, hold on. Oh,
>> why [__] kick him?
>> Yo, why? Nah, bring him back up. All
right.
>> Come on, man. I just want to tell him
I'm not getting ready to have a
conversation.
We know the definition. We're grown as
hell. We know eternity doesn't have a
meaning he doesn't have a beginning.
Meaning what?
>> He's not he's not letting Gary finish.
That's why I'm
>> back. This what we going to do.
>> Hey yo, look hey look um God logic just
allow just look when y'all you just like
how you had that conversation with um
Tazar do here. You know what I mean? I
just you just do it respectfully cuz we
don't want to do you were just talking
over people and big
I've engaged with you before. You were
you were honest before
>> you just saw what happened.
>> Gary asked me a question about origin. I
was in the middle of explaining the
origin from Everlasting and he cut me
off
>> and in me saying please let me finish
let me finish please. You see now I'm
getting cut off again. So watch watch me
get muted while I'm the one. You see,
you see what I'm saying?
>> Nobody Nobody's muted real quick.
>> So, let me finish my point, please, so
we can get some against Israel.
>> So, look, if he if he disagrees with
what I'm saying, there's no problem. Let
me finish my point first and then you
can respond. You know what I'm saying?
We can have a back and forth like that
just like me and Cap did. Me and Cap, we
disagreed. We had a a flowing back and
forth. We interjected sometimes, but you
continue. Let's Let's continue this,
bro, cuz I I need to I won't continue
this. Just just let it let it run.
>> So So yeah, I'll be quiet again. I'll
let Gary finish off what he was saying
and then hopefully I get the same
respect. Is that fair?
>> Yeah, when So you believe that Christ,
we know that you believe that Christ is
eternal, right? But Michael 52 says he
has a meaning he has an origin. The
definition of origin is to have a
beginning. The definition of eternal is
to have no beginning nor end. Can you
rectify that?
>> Yes. When you say your origin, it's
qualified in the verse. It says that his
origins are from everlasting,
meaning he's from eternity. He does not
have a beginning. That's where he's
from. And that's why even even the Bible
says that God is from everlasting to
everlasting. So this is you literally
came to a verse that literally says that
Jesus is infinite and n and uncreated.
>> Bro, if someone if I say I have an
origin, what does that mean?
>> Qualify it. Depends on how you qualify
it, my brother.
>> Okay, let's look at the definition of
the word origin.
>> You're you're not you're not
understanding. Do you know what I mean
when I say
>> No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We're not going to do that. We're going
to look up the definition of these
words.
>> You can look up the definition all you
want.
>> Okay, let's look at the definition of
the word origin, shall we?
>> Okay, go ahead.
>> Combine origin. Let's see what Let's see
if God logic knows common English.
>> Yeah. And let's see if if Gary knows
common context.
>> A point of place where something
arises or a point of place where
something begins. a point again a point
in place where something begins. So now,
do you agree with the actual definition
of the word origin?
>> I sure do. Now, here's my question to
you.
>> Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on. So
when it says,
>> notice how I let you just do this. Back
to you.
>> I'm not finished. So when God So when it
says Christ has an origin, what does it
say?
>> Are you finished now?
>> No, that's my question.
>> Okay. Wait, you just said you're not
finished. I'm going to let you finish.
>> That's a question. That's a question
mark.
>> I know it's a question, but when I start
answering, you're going to want you're
going to say, "No, no, no. I'm not
done." Okay. So, go ahead. When it says
when it says Christ has an origin, the
point in place where something begins,
what does that mean?
>> I got you. So, when you qualify the word
origin in its context, see this is Gary.
This is how words work in sentences.
Words work depending on their context.
And so, when something is qualified in
in context, that's how you derive the
meaning and how it's being used. So for
example, I have no problem with the
definition of origin that you gave the
starting point, right? The starting
point of something. However, when it's
qualified in the sentence, it says that
his starting point is from everlasting.
Does everlasting have a starting point,
Gary?
>> Here we go. Right. Everlasting does have
a starting point in you want to do it in
because it's talking about the father.
If you want to be I mean you want to
play that game, we can play that game in
context.
>> Give me the definition of of ever hold
on. Let's do let's do this real quick.
everlasting eternity. Let's get define
eternity. Let's see what we get up here.
Define eternity.
All right. Eternity.
>> Let's see here.
>> Go ahead.
>> All right. Oh, okay. Noun. Infinite. I I
am I'm reading infinite
>> or unending time. [clears throat]
meaning a state to which time has no
application. Timelessness. So if you're
if you're without time and time has no
application, do you have a beginning?
Does everlasting have a starting point?
>> No, no, no. That's my point. It's
eternal. That's my point. Thank you.
>> So when it says that the origin is from
eternity, that means his origin is based
on timeless.
>> Origin comes from the father. Because we
know the only one who has the object of
eternity is the father.
>> But his it says his origin is outside of
time, brother. It's eternal. Hold on.
Outside outside of outside your belief
that Christ has eternity, who has
eternity?
>> Outside of Christ.
>> Outside of Christ, who has eternity?
>> Uh the father and the spirit.
>> Okay. So if he says he comes from
eternity, who does he say he come from?
>> He comes from eternity. Timelessness,
brother.
>> There's no beginning there.
>> No, that makes zero sense. If I say he
if we know that outside of the outside
of Christ the father father has eternity
and the Christ and it says Christ comes
from eternity who is it saying he come
from?
>> It it says that he's coming from
eternity. Now this this also let me let
me land let me get my full thought out.
This this also points to this also
points to Jesus being eternally
infinitely begotten of the father
because he comes from the father that
his begottenness is not something that
takes place within time.
>> It's outside of time brog you came you
came to a verse you came to a verse
literally says that Jesus is infinite
and eternal.
>> I'm going to ask you every meaning of
these words. What does the word begotten
mean
>> to come forth from? Oh, so he eternally
came. So how do you eternally come forth
from something?
>> If of course. So imagine, let me just
give you this analogy. Imagine that the
sun in the sky you you agree that light
comes forth from the sun.
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
>> Keep going.
>> Do you agree that light comes forth from
the sun?
>> Listen, bro. Hey, make that make sense.
>> No, I'm asking you a question. I'm
building with you. Do you agree that
light comes forth from the sun?
>> Yes, the light comes from the sun.
>> Yes. Okay, good. So if the sun was
eternal, as long as the sun is the sun,
it always gives off light, right? Light
always comes forth from the sun, right?
Right.
>> Bro, stop asking rhetorical questions,
bro.
>> See, you look, you got to be willing to
work with me, man.
>> Well, who the hell is going to disagree
that the sunshine doesn't shine from the
sun? Bro, what does this got to do with
Christ? Come on.
>> I'm I'm We're breaking it down. You kind
It sound like you're nervous about where
this is going. Just work with me. Just
>> I'm not. It's a foolish question, but go
ahead. Go.
>> It's okay. So, look. Um just like how
Jesus gave parables and analogies is
what I'm doing with you as well. So you
agree that light always comes forth from
the sun as long as the sun is the sun.
Very good. So now imagine this Gary this
is hypothetical. Okay. If the sun was
infinite if the sun was eternal never be
never had a beginning. It was infinite.
It would infinitely bring forth light.
Correct
>> bro. Are you trying to put a
hypothetical? Bro
>> I'm not putting a hypothetical on it.
Just answer the question. If the sun was
if the sun was infinite, it would
infinitely bring forth light. Right?
>> I'm not asking a hypothetical question
because the hypothetical goes into
imagination and nonfacts. Anything
outside of yay and nay is evil. So let's
I don't I'm not dealing with
>> So when Jesus didn't answer yay and nay,
was he evil?
>> I'm dealing with hypotheticals. I'm
dealing with
>> I got you. When Jesus didn't When Jesus
didn't answer yay and
>> I'm not dealing with no hypotheticals.
I'm dealing with
>> Okay. So when Jesus didn't answer yay or
nay? No. Show me what these words mean.
When Jesus When Jesus did not answer
Gary, I heard you. When Jesus did not
answer yay or nay, but instead gave an
analogy as an answer, was he evil?
>> I'm not dealing with you. I just told
you that
>> you're not answering my question.
>> And no, he gave No, he gave he gave real
realistic examples. You're giving a
hypothetical.
>> Realistic example.
>> Realistic? No.
>> Was it yay or nay? Was it yay or nay?
Was it yay or nay?
>> Was he gave realistic examples or asking
you to give a realistic,
>> bro? You keep cooking yourself, man.
>> I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm not cooking
myself. You don't know the
>> definition. You're in trouble.
>> What's the definition of begotten?
>> Okay, I already gave that to you, bro.
>> Okay, you said you asked.
Notice how you're running from the
question.
>> Listen. And you said the dumb [__] They
muted me again, guys. Be brought forth.
They muted me again. They're going to
keep muting me to rectify that
realistically. They try to get the boy
get his boy out the
>> We don't want hypotheticals. We not We
need something to be rectified
realistically to realistically rectify
that. I I am realistically rectifying
it. So answer my question, Gary. Answer
my question. If the sun is infinite,
would it infinitely bring forth life?
I'm not hypothetical. Stop asking God.
Hold up, Gary. Hold up, Gary. God lo
this dude running, y'all. I'm tell you
one more time.
>> He's cut. I'm call
How can you be cut by hypothetical
situation? That's dumb. Hypothetical.
>> Hold on, Gary. Gary, hold on. Hey, God
logic, if you keep playing your games,
I'm going to kick your little butt down.
I I know you going to kick it because
you escaped. Give me a realistic answer.
Hey, Big Bear. You see what's happening?
>> Hold on. Both of y'all hold on just just
for a second. Hold on for a second. Look
at these cowards, man.
>> God, it's very simple, bro.
>> What what you're what you're attempting
to do is what I see you do.
>> Using his imagination to make his
answer. That's what you do.
>> Instead of giving me a realistic answer.
[laughter]
>> Exactly. Just Well, I just got here. I
don't even know that argument that y'all
>> talking about the sun shining forever
and this [__] Man, give me a
realistic answer. Realistically rectify
being eternally brought forth from
something.
>> Hey, okay. If that's the case, being
brought forth.
>> Is it okay that I finish my answer, my
brother?
>> No. As long as you long as you don't abs
long as you don't ask.
>> Hey, Big Bear, you there, bro? You see
what's happening? Big second.
>> Hold on. We're going to let you talk.
>> No, you're not. You keep muting me cuz
you're cowards.
>> No, we're not cowards. But one thing for
sure, I ain't scared of nobody. I'll
come
>> then. You're not afraid to answer the
question. You're not afraid of nobody.
>> I'll come with this.
>> Gary Gary and God logic. Hold on for a
second. Please hold on just for a
second. Can we deal with the text?
>> Exactly. Not hypothetical son existing
forever.
>> We don't want to deal with any
philosophy. Deal with the text. Use the
language of the Bible, not some
hypothetical
scenario. That's truly irrelevant.
>> Got nothing to do with nothing.
>> May I respond now?
>> If you'll if you'll respond in kind.
>> I would I would love to respond to what
was just said to me if I could.
>> Okay, go ahead.
>> I appreciate it. You said to use the
language of the Bible, which is what
exactly what I'm doing. It says that the
sun comes from eternity. And so, notice
how I'm already getting interrupted.
Latin heat is not
>> hold.
Allow me. Allow me to finish, guys.
I can't say two words without getting
cut off. What? Why are you cutting me
off right now?
>> Because because we're trying I'm trying
to follow along.
>> I'm trying to If if you listen to me,
I'll tell you. If you just listen.
>> I heard you. But hold on. Are you
talking about the literal son that was
created on the fourth day or you're
talking about
>> If you If you allow me to finish hard,
if you if you allow me to finish what
I'm saying, you will understand what I'm
saying. what what what son I'm talking
about what you're saying
>> if you understood what I'm saying you
wouldn't be asking this question man
allow me to finish and you'll understand
what I'm saying
>> thank you so
how is it that the son the son of god
Jesus the messiah
>> is begotten eternally comes forth from
the father eternally he said can can you
break that down answer that for me I
said definitely and so I begin to give
him an analogy using the sun in the sky
that we have. And so with this analogy,
he was afraid to go to its conclusion
cuz he saw how he was in trouble. So
instead of instead of asking him, Gary,
please allow me to finish, Gary.
>> Add homonyms. How about
>> they me and they cut me off. He's
supposed to be that's supposed to be
strong. That's supposed to be doctrinal.
>> Listen,
no one cares about the ad homonyms, bro.
We don't care. You remember how we
listen, bro? We don't care about oh you
scared you fed this. I don't see no I
love I don't fear no man. I look down
the barrel of a gun. I'm not fear
nobody. Hold on. That's one thing. So
two I'm not scared of nobody. I don't
fear no man or nothing. Just finish the
analogy without the ad hom.
>> Thank you. Everybody listen no one here
here is scared of anybody. Please stop
doing that. That's so immature. That's
like like some eighth grade stuff that
we used to do. Cut that out. Please,
>> you know what's more immature? Not
letting a person speak.
>> Why? Who? Don't kick him, too. Please.
Latin. Latin. Calm down.
>> I'm not upset. I'm not I like God logic.
I just don't like his tactics. You're
upset.
>> Okay. Listen. You're all upset.
>> Let's watch this. It's very Whoever has
listen.
>> Let's listen to me real quick. Whoever
has truth is going to be able to temper
themselves and let anybody give their
dissertation. Exactly. Because if you
have truth, you can come behind them and
clean it up.
>> That's right.
>> So, let's not let's not get upset.
>> Let's be patient. Let's hear each other
out and just just just deal accordingly.
You know what I'm saying?
>> All right. Well, I'm going just tell
him. I'm just going to tell him. Keep
all them keep all that [__] So, so
allow me to finish. I'm I'm only giving
y'all the same energy you gave me.
>> You pretty scholarly, Gary. Gary, you're
pretty scholarly. You don't have to do
that.
>> I know. I'm saying No, I'm just saying
because I'm just saying, bro. I'm just
saying to talk with slight am he ain't
scholarly at all. He can't even handle
this.
>> Hold on. Hold on. Gary. Gary. Gary.
Gary. You're Israel. We're Israel. We're
better than that. We're better than
that. Even though I I got I got out of
hand the other day, but it was like
three or four people against me. So that
>> and I'm not about that. I don't want to
deal with no imaginational thing. I'm
asking him to explain by the definition
of begotten how someone eternally
begotten.
>> So now can I finish what I was saying?
>> But listen listen cut him off. Please
let him speak.
>> Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Let him let him speak
and get his stuff out. And Gary, you uh
you you made your stance. You said you
didn't want to answer that uh in that
manner. So let's just at least entertain
it. Go ahead.
>> I appreciate it. So when someone can't
follow an analogy, it shows that they're
afraid of where this goes because they
see the answer. So continuing with the
analogy, Gary Gary said that logic don't
>> I said three words and I got cut off,
bro. I said three words and I got cut
off.
>> Hold on. Hold on.
>> This is This is getting insane, man.
>> Hold on. I'mma give you back the floor.
But don't don't pride at him. You see,
he he
>> I'm talking to him. It don't matter. We
Israel doing I know. I know. No. No.
Gary. Gary. Gary's not soft, right?
Gary, you're not soft.
>> Darius. Darius. Gary. Dary. Dary. We're
not going to But we're not going to play
games, though.
>> Go ahead.
>> The only way I can show a [__] is not
soft to see you in person. But
>> don't
chill out. Chill out.
>> Listen. I just asked [__] stop that
[__] ass [__] cuz I see in person, bro,
he not going to be like that. Calm down,
Gary. Please calm down. That's what I'm
seeing.
>> Hold on. I'm just letting you know. I'm
not from that type of place. Hold on.
I'm not from that type of place.
>> Check this out. Check this out. Yo. Yo,
just chill, man.
I'm not 30, 50 years old, bro. I ain't
that old. I ain't going to.
>> Hey, Gary, we already know. Just let him
get it out. Let him do all the the
homonyms. This is just talk, bro. Like,
let's just go. Let him talk. Y
a little harder than this, man. Listen,
bro. I'm from talking get you hurt and
God like you're a public figureary.
Gary Gary, let it go. But man,
>> hold on. Hold on. Gary, let it go.
I wasating this conversation before you
real quick. I was moderating this before
you even came up here, bro. So, don't
call back. I got it. I've been had it
the whole time, bro. I was I was
moderating this whole thing before you
ever came up. Fall back. I got you
respectfully. I didn't mean but y'all
muting me. But respectfully, I was
moderating the whole conversation. I got
it, bro. Like me and Gary good witness.
>> Yeah. Relax. Like yo, look. But Gary
Gary grown. He know he know what he's
doing. Like I know I know Gary. Gary
cool. But just let them talk, bro. Like
that's what we was doing.
>> Logic. I'm not
>> Yo, but you But they was in the midst of
a conversation though. That's all right,
dog. This is my This is
>> I just want you to spit out this
hypothesis of this
>> my congregation, bro. I'm not going to
have that here.
>> No, look, no. First of all, look, I know
Joelle. Joelle is me and him. This is me
and him, too. Like, what are you talking
about? You You just came in and just
trying to take over and this the whole
thing. We was already having a
conversation before you came.
>> I'm not trying to take over.
>> All right. Well, fall back and mute your
mic because I was moderating the whole
thing before you came up.
>> Hey. Hey, bro. Big Listen, bro. As long
as we can keep let's just keep the
tension down. So I'mma act God logic,
bro. I'm not like that. I'm not like
that. I don't do all that tough Tony
talking. I don't slight all ham saying
[__] scared. None of that [__] because
if I was really in your person and I
pressed you like that, you would try to
whip out your Bible.
>> So again,
we all good now.
>> All that Hold on. Keep all that slick
shot [__] to yourself.
>> We We all good?
>> Yeah. No, just please can we just drop
it right there and just get back to
where it was just peaceful.
>> Don't for you keep on jumping in, bro.
>> Be quiet, bro.
>> Quiet. I'm not talking to you.
>> No, man. What are you talking about,
man? Get out of here, bro.
>> Man, get out of here, man. Like, no,
man. Because he trying to take like
control order when I already we already
had something established before you
came up and you Avery, can you go ahead
uninterrupted? Please go.
>> All right. So with the analogy
that I was given, man, this kind of just
kind of threw me off here. If the sun is
infinite, then it infinitely brings
forth light. Light will be infinitely
brought forth, eternally brought forth
from the sun, right? Because the sun is
infinite. So that is an example of how
something can be eternally brought
forth. Similarly, the father because the
father is eternally the father
infinitely the father he eternally
begets the son. So the son infinitely
eternally is brought forth from the
father. It does not happen in time. So
that's how Jesus can be from eternity,
right? Just like how God it say says
about God that God is from everlasting
to everlasting. Jesus is eternally from
the father, eternally brought forth from
the father, not in time. He's not
created. This is exactly what this verse
says in Micah 5:2.
>> Okay, let's see. Okay, let's see what is
Let's see if that Let's see what that
said. Let's see if that fits the
definition of this word. Begotten to
bring into existence, but Christ doesn't
have an origin. Uh, what definition did
you just read?
>> Oh, this is the Oxford dictionary.
Begotten to be brought into existence.
>> Let's Let's do this really quick. Let's
do this really quick. Define
>> definitions of the word.
>> Define begotten.
>> Watch this. All right. Be. We got give
rise to, bring about. Where are you
seeing bring into existence? That's not
necessarily true. The Oxford dictionary
typically of a man something or or
something of a woman or a child to be
brought into existence. That's the
Oxford dictionary.
>> That's one of the definitions. That's
not the only one. The one I'm saying is
what I'm saying is to is to bring bring
forth.
>> Does any Hold on. Does anything in
English does anything in English trump
the Oxford dictionary?
>> I'm sorry.
>> Does anything in English trumps the
Oxford dictionary? Yes or no?
>> Ox the Oxford dictionary is not the only
dictionary. Dude,
>> I'm not asking you that. I'm asking you
what is the what is the I'm not asking
you that this is the only dictionary and
everyone knows that. I'm asking you what
trumps it in English. What other English
dictionary
>> it's not it's not about what trumps
about the definition that's given.
Notice how you as you asked me a
question. You asked me a question and
you're cutting me off already. Let me
finish.
>> No, that was a rhetorical question.
>> No, you made it for me to answer. It was
not rhetorical. You asked me. So if we
know that the Oxford if we know that the
Oxford dictionary is the authority on
the English language hold on the word be
got the word be I can just look it up I
will show you like
>> what you mean all the [__] language
what are you talking about
>> why you cussing man relax it's all good
that's how I speak
>> that's how I speak but we not Christians
we don't we speak hard up here you talk
>> you don't you're not you're not
operating in the spirit
>> come on don't talk about why you cussing
cuz I can do what I I'm grown.
>> That's right. You operate in the flesh.
>> So, let's go to the Oxford. Let's go to
the Oxford dictionary and let's see if
it's the authority on the English
language
>> based on what? What the heck? Look at
that. You better type, boy. He typing
over there.
>> The Oxford dictionary, the principle and
historical dictionary of the English
language. So again, there's nothing in
the English language that trumps this.
So when the Oxford dictionary says
begotten means to be brought forth into
existence, that's what it means. All
that [__] you taught in God logic
does not trump this because no linguist
or historian will ever tell you that
that that's not that's not what that
word means. The word means to be brought
into existence.
>> Okay. Thank you. So now I'm looking at
these def dictionaries.
Notice how notice how I let you finish.
Are you cutting me off?
>> The linguist will the language
>> they muted me guys. Don't agree with
you.
>> I'm trying to I'm trying to engage with
you and you guys keep muting me like
cowards.
>> You could I didn't mute you, bro. You
could have unmuted for you could have
unmuted a minute ago. I I got you. Thank
you. I appreciate it. So, I'm looking at
all these dictionaries here. We got
Miriam Webster's dictionary. We got we
got uh dictionary.com. We got Collins
dictionary. And in all of these
dictionaries, talking about how Notice
how I didn't interrupt you. Notice how I
didn't interrupt you. Self-control, my
brother.
>> In all of these definitions, they all
give beget a definition of bringing
forth or producing. bringing forth or to
bring about, not necessarily bringing
into existence. So, the context will
tell you, excuse me, Gary,
>> the context will tell you how the word
is being used, especially if we're using
it biblically. When we're using it
biblically, we see that Jesus isn't made
even though he's begotten.
>> Oh, wait, wait, wait. The the whole
point of the whole point of this is Gary
is that you went to a verse
>> that literally tells us
>> that Jesus is from eternity.
And if you want to talk about
dictionaries, your dictionary that
you're appealing to says eternity is
timelessness
without time outside.
>> No beginningitude.
That's what you're
>> No beginning nor end. No beginning. from
eternity. Does he have a beginning
>> from Christ? Yes. Now, moving on.
>> You just contradicted yourself.
>> Now, now moving on. Let's see. So, he
said the word he said in that
dictionary. He said in that dictionary,
the word producer, he says the word
produce. Let's see what the word produce
means, guys. Definition of the word
produce to cause to a particular
situation to come to into existence or
to happen. So Christ was a particular
thing that was caused or produced or to
be brought forth or to be begotten,
meaning brought into existence. They're
all synonyms. Goofy, do you not know
what a synonym is? Do you? Synonym a
different word with the same definition.
Brother, I I think [laughter]
I think that you don't know how how
language notice what you're doing here.
You just you you continue to destroy
yourself. They keep hitting me, guys.
They keep muting the the clowns that
keep muing me on this chat is amazing.
You guys Why you guys keep stepping in
to save your boy?
>> They keep stepping on to you, man.
>> I'm talking. I'm trying to talk to the
chat.
>> But you cut me off. I was in the middle
of talking and you cut me off and now
your boys are mean to me again.
>> This is This is insane.
>> I know. I know you die. I know I'm
spitting. Thank you. I know I'm
spitting. Thank you, sister.
>> Is it Is it okay moderators that I could
finish what I was saying?
>> I'm the moderator, bro. That's I'm my
moderator. muted me then. So you're the
one muted.
>> So don't No, let me
>> So you're the one muted me like a
coward.
>> No, I'm speaking.
>> Well, you cut me off. I was already
speaking.
>> I'm I'm speaking. You feel
>> I'm going to tell you this. The word
produce, you just said, "Oh, it means
Hold on. If you look at
>> There's no hold on. You got to hold on,
bro. It's not your turn.
>> There's a hold on cuz there it is."
Listen. So if you look at all of those
words that's in any of those
dictionaries, they're all synonyms. They
all have the same definition. Goofy,
come on now. You usually try to make it
like that mean though they all have the
same definition. You look up what the
produce means. It means to manufacture
out of raw materials. The second one.
The second one to cause a particular
situation to happen or to bring
something into existence. What are you
talking about, bro? You just saying
anything. I'm again I'm not Hold on.
Again, I'm not going to have a
conversation with a grown man who don't
know the definition of words and how
synonyms are used. You grown as [__] and
don't know the basic English language.
>> Can I respond now? Hey, and go ahead
every uninterrupted, please.
>> All right. I appreciate it. So, now now
I'm going to try to attempt to talk to a
grown man who's just cussing and has no
decorum and self-control.
>> You're over here taking verses out. I'm
not sorry. Taking words out of their
context. You don't know how the language
works. No, notice he unmuted already.
Unmuted already. No self-control.
>> No self-control.
>> Please let him go,
>> Gary.
>> This is how language works, my brother.
I want you to listen carefully. When
we're using language, words are uh what
determines the meaning of a word is the
context that it's used in. Notice
already. Ma, are you going to mute him?
>> Gary,
>> stop panicking, Gary. It's okay, Gary.
>> Then relax, Gary. Stop panicking. Just
chill. I'm trying to teach you how
language works.
>> No, you're not.
>> These these words can be used in
different context. And the context,
guys. No self-control.
>> All right, back.
>> No self-control.
>> I'm in the chat, bro. I'm going to let
you go for entertainment.
>> Gary, relax.
>> No, Avery. Go ahead. We got cut off
every time, bro.
>> Okay, I got you. Go ahead, brother.
>> So, how language works, how words work,
Gary, is the context tells us their
usage. I hope you understand. I'll say
it again. Context determines the usage
of a word. We learned this in third
grade, my guy, probably even before
that. So, when you're coming to
dictionaries and giving definitions of
certain words that do not you're you
even read a word a definition that
doesn't even go with how you're trying
to interpret the word. The use the
context determines the usage. So when we
talk about coming forth from
begottenness
producing
a source right the or the the context
tells us how it's being used for Jesus
for example Jesus comes from eternity
which you already conceded that eternity
doesn't have a beginning and then you
contradicted yourself later and said
eternity does have a beginning. I'm
talking to a grown man who cannot who
cannot pick his position. Whether
eternity means you have a beginning or
you don't have a beginning. I'm lost,
but I'm talking to a grown man right
here. So, in conclusion, this is where
we're at. We have Jesus is from
eternity. And we have Jesus, who by the
way is the word of God in John 1:3, who
says, "All things were created through
him, and not one thing that has been
created was created without him." So
Gary, here's my question to you. Since
you want to insist that Jesus was
created, answer this question for me.
Since all things that has ever been
created according to the Bible was
created through Jesus. My question to
you is was Jesus created through Jesus?
Please answer directly and don't waffle
and waste my time. Was Jesus created
through Jesus?
>> You go uninterrupted. You go last
question, right? Because I simply just
told I simply just we simply had a
conversation earlier. That's how I know
he wasn't listening. He just made up
that lie about me saying that I said
that Christ was eternal. But as I
clearly told him that Christ, we know
that the father is eternity. He is the
existing one. So when Christ said he
came from he came from everlasting, he
came from the existing one. Right? So he
is he came from the father. So don't ask
me no dumbass question when we already
when I already established that Christ
came from the father.
>> All right. So you didn't answer the
question. So I'll ask it again. The
Bible says that Jesus
>> it's through Jesus that everything was
created. Did I answer that question yet?
>> What's going on here? He's cutting me
off again. He's cutting me off again.
>> He's cutting me off again.
>> Just said I answered the question.
>> Notice how he's cutting me off again.
Moderator, you guys going to step in and
stop him.
>> Answer that question. Did I ask that
question?
>> You guys going to stop him?
>> Are you guys going to stop him?
>> Yeah, I am. Look, check this out.
>> All right, let me finish. Let me
>> let me engage with him, please.
>> No, you did not. I I'll do it again.
>> I'm not asking you anything. I'm asking
the mugs. I'm asking
>> Hey, moderators, man. If you guys keep
hitting me, man. I know I know you guys
want me to give me a reason to leave.
that question.
>> I'll leave you guys to yourself. This
just shows that this shows we're
Israelites, y'all soft.
>> Can I please do this? Brother Gary, you
did answer the question. Brother Avery
is doing the semantic thing. We all know
that. That's why we're Israelites and
we're above that. We I know you answered
the question, Gary. I know we know
Avery's tactics. We know how Christians
work. This is what I'm trying to
explain. Us Israelites, we are above
that. We got to show that. You answered
the question, brother Gary. Let Avery do
that. Let him do what he do. We know
what that is. He done it many, plenty of
times. He did it against Captain Tazarak
is still lost. Brother Gary, you
answered it. Don't get emotional. We are
Israel. We are above that. Avery, go
ahead.
>> Appreciate it. Yeah. To think that
Captain Tazar won, you got to be
delusional. Um just as delusional here.
If you're if you're saying I appreciate
it. You didn't answer the question,
Gary. What What's up with y'all, man?
Like, y'all supposed to be Israelites.
Y'all supposed to be hard. Y'all
supposed to be tough.
>> Hey yo, chill. I think it's somebody. I
think
>> y'all up here weird, man. What is this,
bro?
>> Hold on. No, don't mute this mic.
Whoever mut Oh yeah, my bad. No, the
host muted him. The host mut.
>> Okay, so host is weird. He on that weird
stuff.
>> Hey,
better than that. Why are y'all falling
for that?
>> Calm down, little man. Calm down.
>> All right, so stop being weird and let
your boy get cooked. Stop muting me.
>> We can be weird all So anyway, so uh
Gary, since you you feel like you answer
the question, if you follow the same
delusion as Captain Dar, can you you
could you could drop me clown if you
want. This just shows y'all running.
This shows y'all running. You guys are
cowards.
>> Just y'all suck like Muslims.
>> Now I got to hold right now. Now I got
to hold us accountable. We are being
carnal as hell. Can we stop falling for
his damn tricks? We know he's a
Christian.
>> Bro, I'm having fun up there, bro. I
ain't Well, I'm trolling. I'm having fun
up here. I'm having a good conversation
with him, but I'm troll. You want to
troll him or troll him back, bro. If he
wants to troll, I'm going to troll him
back.
>> Okay, brother.
>> Y'all just continue. Y'all just
continue. Go ahead. Hey, got um Who want
>> So, he answered your question. I heard
>> in the middle of speaking.
>> But yeah, look, he answered your
question. Y'all could go on another
topic.
>> Yeah, go ahead.
>> I'm I'm going to address what he said
cuz he didn't answer my question. And
let me tell you why. The reason why he
didn't answer my question is because
this was my question. My question was
according to John 1:3 when it says that
Jesus, it's through Jesus that all
things were created and not one thing
that has been created was created
without him. My question was, so was
Jesus created through Jesus according to
your theology? And he did not answer
that. He went on waffling about
something else. I'll give you another
chance. I'm a man of many chances just
like my Lord.
>> My Lord gave me many chances. I'm I'mma
ask you again. I'mma give you another
chance. Gary. Gary, please pay
attention. Gary,
>> do not waffle on something I did not ask
you.
>> I'm do.
>> Was Jesus created through Jesus? Yes or
no?
>> Okay. So, I'm going to say again, I've
already established to you that Christ
was created by the father. It says in
Micah 5:2, he came from everlasting. We
know that everlasting is eternity. We
know the it's the most high, the father,
because he's the existing one. He is the
one who holds eternity. So when he said
he came from everlasting, he came from
eternity and he he came from eternity,
he was telling you he came from the
existing one, meaning he was produced by
the actual creator.
>> Thank you. Thank you for another
non-answer. According to John 1:3, was
anything created without Jesus? Gary,
>> well, I'm not asking no question. I just
question.
>> He's done, y'all.
>> Well, hold on. You So you said Christ
created all Hold on. But yeah, so if
Christ created all things, did he create
himself?
>> Yeah, they muted me.
>> So that just shows that he will have an
origin, right?
>> I got I got muted. I got muted, big
bear. I'm trying to talk to you.
>> Yeah, that's Christ.
>> So can I can I can I answer you? Can I
answer you, Big Bear?
>> Yeah, go ahead.
>> I appreciate you, bro. Hopefully. So I'm
I'm dialog I'm dialoguing with you now,
Gary. Gary forfeited. I'm I'm talking
with you now, Big Bear.
>> So to answer your question to answer
your question, Gary, you you're you
forfeited, bro. Don't ask me nothing
until you answer my question. You don't
want to talk to me. You're done.
>> You don't want to talk to false witness.
He did not force. You can
>> say that again.
>> He did. He just said he's not going to
answer the question.
>> You don't want to talk to simple
doesn't mean look look. I look I got no
problem continuing to beat a dead horse.
I have no problem with that. Big bear.
Am I am I talking to Gary or Big Bear?
Which one?
>> No, no, no. You go ahead and talk to
Gary cuz I want you.
>> Okay. Okay. I'll I'll still talk to
Gary. So Gary, answer the question and
stop running
>> on a plank. I know. I know.
I know, but your question is on the
plate after my question.
>> My question was, was there anything
created without Jesus? Yes or no, Gary?
>> I g I gave you that. I gave you that
already. I gave that answer.
>> No, you did not. Was anything according
to John? Listen, if you want
>> according to John 13, was there anything
created that without Jesus?
>> Can't help an ungrateful child.
>> Answer the question. Answer the
question. Answer the question.
>> That's what I thought. You're a coward.
I'll talk to you, big man. He's done. My
question, my question is to you, right?
>> If Christ created everything, did he
create the father?
>> Big bear, do you want to do you want to
>> if Christ, if Christ created everything,
did he create the father?
>> So, it looks like this is it, huh? I'm
getting muted.
>> This is it. So, did Christ appear?
>> Hey, big bear. Big bear. Big bear.
>> That question is on thing. Ask that
question.
>> Bear with brother.
>> Did Christ create the father?
>> Did he answer my question just now? Big
bear
>> did. Yes.
>> What? What question? What? The question
that I asked about John 13 when I asked
was anything created without Jesus. Did
he answer that?
>> He going to he going he look he's asking
you with the with the question that he
asked me because he asked you did Christ
create the father.
>> But did he answer my question?
>> That will answer your question that will
answer.
>> So So we agree he did not answer the
question.
>> No no no no. Answer the question.
>> So do we agree that he didn't answer the
question that he's dodging and he's
trying to ask me another question?
>> Listen, bro. You in a place I told you,
bro. You going to troll. I can do
exactly that. I love trolling, bro.
>> I'm talking to you, bro. I'm talking to
you, man. I'm asking you to bear with
us, bro.
>> I will literally troll you all day. I'm
letting you know that. So, if we're
going to be
>> You see why I invited you to my panel,
bro?
>> None of this foolish.
>> I'm not going none of this. None of this
foolishness will be handled.
>> None of this foolishness will go on. I
can just
>> You guys as Israelites, you guys mute
the Christians. You cut us off. You
don't let us talk. You dodge questions.
This is [laughter] embarrassing.
>> I propose a question. You better fall as
a
>> father.
>> All right, I'm I'mma make my rounds,
man. I appreciate y'all, man. This This
was embarrassing. Gary, you gotta try
again, dude.
>> Man, I appreciate
>> easy cowards. You Hebrew Israelites are
some of the easiest cowards to deal
with. Easiest. Y'all are easy, man.
Easy. You call yourself Israelites, you
fake Israelites. You can't have no
discussion. You got to yell over people.
When you can't do that, when you can't
mute, you're done on a on an equal
platform. You're done. You can't engage
scripturally. You can't engage
logically. You can't engage
philosophically. You're done. Trash.
Trash logic. Trash. Trash. Cult. Can't
handle a Christian. Not a real one.